Hi, everyone.
My name is Sean Spitzer, senior instructor for Epic Games.
And today, we're going to be talking about ICVFX tools
using web remote, Blueprints, and LevelSnapshot.
So let's go ahead and get started.
Some of the things we're going to be talking about today
are going to be looking at the overview of everything,
the setting up, creating the remote control preset,
organizing and installing the web app,
connecting to your iPad or mobile device,
your overall workflow, and adding property widgets,
as well as editing widgets, testing, and web application
tab options.
There's a lot to unpack here, but don't let it intimidate
you.
This actually is a pretty easy tool to use.
It'll just take some time to make sure you're invested
and looking at all the options that you have,
because there will be quite a bit.
So let's explain, first up, the overview of what
the remote control API does.
It's a subset of the remote control preset.
This offers a simplified approach.
So the remote control preset, or RCP,
you'll hear me say this a lot, streamlined approach
to working with a remote control API.
So it streamlines it for us.
It makes it easier for us to access
and to be able to build and create
a little more customization when it comes to control.
So we're going to quickly expose our UI parameters
and functions, AKA properties.
We're going to modify those properties in Unreal,
and we're going to connect those properties to widgets
in the web application.
So we're going to cover those later on in the slides.
You'll be able to see some of the cool things you can do.
You'll see a link here that I have
in my slides for remote control presets and web application.
So feel free to go through there
and navigate into the version that you need.
And what I mean by version is Unreal Engine version.
So let's take a look at the setup.
So it's really important to consider and turn
on the appropriate plugins to get things
in the right direction.
So let's go ahead and go to Unreal
and talk about what you need to do.
So in Unreal, we're going to go to Edit.
We're going to go to our plugins here.
We want to make sure that we actually get all the ones
that we need.
Now, this does change per workflow or production,
whatever you're using.
You might say, hey, I just want to use DMX and nothing
else, and you're more than welcome to do that.
But let's go and turn these on
so I can show you exactly where they are located.
So I'm going to type in remote control,
and you'll see we'll have several presets or several tools
that we have up that we can activate
to be able to have access to them to use them
for remote control.
One of them for sure you do have to turn on no matter what
is our remote control API.
This is going to allow us to be able to use our RPC
or remote control preset like we just mentioned.
You'll see also we have remote control protocol DMX,
and we have remote control protocol MIDI,
and remote control protocol OSC.
And you also want to turn on your remote control web
interface.
So all of these you do want to turn on.
But in some cases, you may not want MIDI,
you may not want OSC, you may not want DMX.
It just depends on what your production is.
But for good practice, I actually
like to make sure all of this is on and ready to go.
OK, so we're going to close that.
You'll see that mine are on already.
In many cases, you're going to have to restart.
So we've got ours all set up and ready to go.
What we want to do is make sure
once we have that all set in is
we want to take a look at some of our project settings
here.
So this is really important to consider.
So let's actually do that.
So I'm going to go to edit.
I'm going to go to my project settings,
and I'm going to pop that up.
In my project settings, we want to take a look at our plugins.
And in our plugins, we want to make sure
that we're looking at our options
here for our remote control.
So let's go and take a look at that.
I'm going to scroll down a bit.
Let's go to remote control.
And you actually can type these in too if you need to.
So I'm under plugins right now,
clicking on remote control.
And I'm popping this up here into my interface.
You'll see we have protocols to generate transactions.
That's on by default.
And you also want to go and check your remote control web
interface, HTTP port.
Now, I'm going to keep this at 30,000.
And that's kind of where you want to work
when you're working with this.
Again, Unreal gives you the option
to customize whatever the heck that you need.
So if you do need to change these things,
just consider how your output's going to be.
But for our usage and what we're doing,
we definitely want to keep this here.
And default works really well for what we're doing.
We want to make sure we leave checked Auto Start web
server and Auto Start web socket server.
So you want to make sure those are on here.
And these are going to help us with this remote control
preset.
All right, I'm going to close that out.
So let's go ahead.
We're going to now build.
Let's go and look at the slides just for a moment.
We're now going to build our remote control preset.
And it's pretty easy to do so.
So some of these slides I will not go to.
I'm just doing it right at this moment.
What we want to do is eventually go in here
and spend most of our time in Unreal
today, because there's a lot of things to cover.
But it's really literally just you right click
and we go to remote control.
Reason why I'm in this slide, I
want to point out that this has changed between 5.0 and 5.1.
Before, you would have to go to miscellaneous to get to this.
But now we have his own section here,
because he's a special little guy.
He has his own section here where it says remote control
and remote control preset.
And that's kind of where you want
to live when it comes to getting your stuff ready to go.
So let's go back to Unreal.
And we're going to do exactly that.
So I'm going to go ahead and go to my remote control preset.
Now, I already have our remote control preset area.
I just generically put my MPC.
Normally, I put my MPC in a separate folder.
But I just left it here for reference purposes.
So I'm going to go ahead and I'm
going to right click for a second.
And I'm going to go to remote control.
And I'm going to go to my remote control preset.
Now, again, in 5.0 and 5.1, this is different.
You would actually go to miscellaneous
and you would find your remote control.
But now we have it so you have your own section.
So I'm going to click on remote control preset.
This one will be our new in class.
So we'll call this RCP underscore new in class.
There you go.
Now, I'm not connected to source control
right now because I'm just going to rip these out later.
But again, you want to make sure that you're adding
and you're connecting to source control as needed.
So I have my remote control preset.
I'm going to double click this.
Now, if you've worked with remote control preset before,
you will notice a significant interface difference now.
It's very much changed.
And the fact that we've added and re-categorized
a few things.
One of them being protocols, which
we'll talk about in just a bit.
This allows you to map control
for DMX and other devices.
You'll also see we have a setup and orientation.
You can do some of that here.
We're going to be doing some of our setup and organization
through our web app as well.
You also see we have browse and save.
And that's pretty straightforward stuff here.
But some of this stuff such as, hey,
there's a details area now.
And there's an expose area.
Down below, you'll see there's an area where you can also
map your blueprints.
And we'll talk about that in just a bit.
We just don't have the tool tips active on them right now.
So when you float over, they're
really not going to tell you what they do until you
actually click on them.
And you can find out and see what they do.
All right, so this remote control preset we have active.
But you'll notice we have some things at the top that
are giving us some questions.
One of them says a passphrase is disabled.
What that means is we actually need to go into Unreal.
And we need to actually find out exactly if things
have started up correctly, which
we'll talk about in just a bit.
And I'm going to jump a little bit ahead
with the slides here just so that you
understand how this works.
You do need to make sure in Unreal
that you get a web tool is active.
This is really important.
I'm going to point that out in just a second here.
Because having that web tool active
allows you to actually make sure that your stuff is
being read correctly.
So one second here.
And what I mean by that is if you go to your output log,
you can actually see, if I type in success,
you can actually see if the web interface has successfully
launched.
And I'm going to move this over.
And you'll see it's running.
And you'll see that also the CUDA API, that's good.
That's not really what we're worried about.
This is what we want to be concerned about right here.
We want to make sure that that web is working according
to what we need.
Now, we can type in the full.
Let's actually get a little bit more into this here.
So we say control web interface plugin.
We have the web socket remote.
Looks like we're good.
We should be good to go.
Cool.
Now, up here, you'll go back to the interface here.
We'll click on this warning.
Task phrase is disabled.
If we click this, we now actually
are enabled so that we can launch this to the web.
Now, what's happening there is that information,
when that usually pops up, it's just
Unreal giving you a checklist to make sure
things are working correctly.
Once I clicked on that, we should be good to go.
And what I mean by that is if I clicked on my web app
right now, I would automatically go
to a viewer, which shows that I am now talking
to the web application.
If I connect this to my iPad, which we'll do later,
you'll actually see the same type of interface
where you can click on the tab
and you can click on Control, and you
can decide how you're going to handle your design.
And we're going to do that in just a bit,
but I wanted to point that out real quick.
So don't let that symbol confuse you,
because in older versions of working with the Royal
Control preset, that sometimes would show up
when your JSON, when your script for this tool
isn't working correctly, and it would be yellow.
In this case, we're just making sure
that everything is active and talking to each other,
and we can see that it's actually working at this time.
So we're in a good spot.
All right, so we got this going on.
And let's actually go back to the slides for a moment.
The next slide here, you'll see it's
doing exactly what I talked about here,
where we're actually getting our remote control preset set up.
But what we want to do is we want to actually populate it,
because right now, it's naked.
There's nothing in there, and we need to put things in there
so we have full control.
I wanted to do a quick check to make sure my JSON wasn't
interfering.
Now, there's a note on that.
I'm going to say this later on in the lecture today,
is in 5.0, there was an issue where
we had a new pixel streaming that we introduced,
and it would override the script that would activate
the web remote control.
And you had to actually go back
to an older version of JSON, and you
had to fix your script back to be able to make
it go in the right direction.
So it's reading older code versus the new code,
which has been introduced.
Now, that might seem confusing, but it's all within my notes
if you guys are working with 5.0 and you run into that.
But we're going to, again, we're focusing on 5.1.
But I kept it in my notes just so that you can keep
those things in mind if, for some reason,
you're running into a conflict because of our pixel streaming
that we've now introduced.
All right, let's go back to Unreal,
and let's populate a few things.
Now, I already have a cake version of this
that's already up and running, but I'm
going to show you how to get this populated.
So I'm going to go ahead and grab my light
in my environment here.
So I have my light up close so I can grab it.
You'll notice off to the right,
we have a little dot to click to expand the toolbar.
So we're going to go straight to intensity,
and I'm going to click this here.
And this will say Expose Property.
Now, these are now active and showing up
because we're working with our remote control preset.
So if I click on my Expose Property,
you'll see that now populate within my remote control
preset, which is pretty nice.
Now, we're working with Lumen, so this
is great because now I have full control
if I want to make it bright or if I want to make it dark.
Now, there is, be careful when you do this,
doing the Control-Z on this can be tricky.
It will not take, so you've got to be careful with that.
So if you just remember where you parked,
like I always say, just remember what your settings were
before when you do that.
So let's actually load the light color.
If you miss that, I'll do it again.
Click on the dots here.
This is Expose Property.
Expose that right there.
So now we've exposed the color,
and we've exposed the intensity.
This is really great.
We now have a bit of control.
Let's also get our rotation in here, too.
So I'm going to click on Rotation.
Click on the dots here to expose that,
and we're going to say Expose Property.
And then now we have Rotation.
Pretty fantastic to be able to have that.
And anytime you can rename these if you need to,
and it's actually nice to be able to do that.
There also, you'll see that there's rebinding.
We'll talk a bit about that.
That allows you to send things to another level,
into another object if you need to, another level.
It's up to you.
In this case, we're not going to do that
in this particular exercise.
We're going to mainly focus on the level that we're in,
but I'll point out those properties
and the things that you are able to do.
And they're also in my documentation
if you decide that you want to dive in that
a little bit deeper.
Let's go back to the slides.
Now, one of the things we want to run into,
you see that we have now populated,
and again, if you're following along,
make sure that you low rotation, intensity,
and light color, pretty much everything I just did.
You want to make sure that you save
your remote control preset.
In my case, I'm not going to save it
just because I already have a cake version,
but we're going to look at that cake version later on.
So you'll notice that I mentioned
some of the interface has changed,
and you'll notice that there's a protocol
and a logic button up at the top.
We're not going to talk too much about logic,
but we definitely will be talking about protocol
because protocol allows us to be able to edit
and to be able to choose
where we want to send our information to.
Basically, if we want to use DMX,
or if we want to use MIDI, or any other device,
and you'll see the listing of them here.
Now, I'm not going to go through every single protocol,
but I have listed what they do
and what those properties are within my notes,
just because it takes a lot of time,
and it may not be pertinent for everybody
to know all about MIDI,
to know all about the settings for OSC.
So we've now populated our RCP.
We've brought in, again, our rotation,
our intensity, and our light color.
Some of the things to consider,
just a little quick review.
You also want to make sure, again,
that that eye is active within that object that you have.
And you'll see us do that a little bit more again
in our scene.
So we're going to save that RCP.
Once we get back in the engine,
we'll do that in just a second.
And we'll take a look at some more things,
such as the interface, which will be our next slide.
So in the interface, again,
you'll notice that we have new protocols and logic.
We're not going to spend really any time
with the logic side,
but we're definitely going to be talking about protocols
and mapping those items that you've exposed in Unreal
to such things as DMX and MIDI and OSC.
Now, again, you may not need any of these
except for maybe DMX,
or you may go straight into your iPad.
I don't know, this depends on your production
and the equipment that you have.
So just consider those things
when we turn on the plugins,
what it is that you need to have active.
Now, binding has changed a bit, and we'll talk about that.
And that has to do with our protocols.
That has changed in 5.1.
So let's take a look at that up close
and a little bit more of the interface stuff with Unreal.
So let's go ahead and go to Unreal to take a peek.
So in Unreal,
you'll notice that we have some grouping methods.
So I'm going to talk about this really quick
because this is a little bit confusing,
even to me when I saw the new changes for things.
You'll notice we have our intensity,
our light color, and our relative rotation.
Just for the heck of it,
let's put in one more item in here
just so you can actually see how things are working.
So in this case, we'll just play with,
we'll just put a rock in here for now.
And the rock, if we wanted to expose it,
we'll expose his location.
And we can do that since we're using Lumen.
We can move this rock on a fly.
So I'm going to click on this and say Expose Property.
And now you'll see the rock shows up,
but you'll notice he's kind of smushed
within all of our stuff.
At any time, I can change the name of these.
So if I wanted to right-click in here
and say, let's rename this,
we're going to go and call this guy just beach rock,
if we want to.
Beach rock underscore up close.
And now he's, we're now able to rename things
and we can shuffle things,
but we can also create groups.
So if I wanted to create a group,
I can create a new group called lights or lights,
or in this case, we'll say key light.
There we go.
So be our main light that we're working with.
And you'll notice in all,
has all of our properties together.
But if I wanted to,
I can drag what I need into key light.
So I can click on these little dots and go to intensity
and pull it right into key light.
If I want to go back in here and say color,
I can pull color into the key light if I wanted to.
If I wanted to go to all again,
I can say, oh, I need my rotation too.
I can move that in rotation
or make groups such as a light rotation,
light color and light intensity.
All those things are there.
The nice thing is we have all,
it shows everything that we have exposed
and the groups allow us to actually isolate things
according to what we need.
Pretty cool.
And again, this has changed quite a bit.
If you're used to 5.0.
So 5.1 has some new organization abilities that you have.
Now protocols.
Now notice when I turn this off,
that DMX OSC and MIDI options disappear.
And when I turn it on,
I now can choose between any of these.
Now in my notes,
I break down the specifics on what are the options mean
for each one of these,
but we're not going to get into that too much
because we also do have a DMX class
and the other ones you can research based on your needs.
So if I click say an example DMX,
you'll notice I can't really do anything in 5.0
allowed us to be able to bind it.
We can't do it right now
because we need to actually select our topic.
So if I'm using DMX,
I need to tell DMX what I'm using.
So in this case,
I'm going to actually bind my intensity.
So with that selected DMX and my light intensity,
I can now add the binding of DMX
because I have it selected and I can say add binding.
And it will automatically bring up in here
the options for DMX and I can choose them
according to what I need.
And if I go back to intensity,
you'll see it there.
It's all ready to go.
And again, we're not going to explore all these details.
We get into some of these very much so in our other classes
but I wanted to point that out
that that's how you would get to that particular item.
And if you need to get rid of the binding, you can.
You can delete that if you want to.
Oh, I shouldn't say there.
You should hit the X.
Don't hit this one.
This will get rid of entities
if you have anything with blueprint loaded.
But over here, we can just kill it if we needed to
and say, oh, I didn't like that setup or I don't.
Oops, I forgot I needed MIDI and not DMX.
You can actually nuke it right there.
So that's pretty much a breakdown of our protocols.
Now, logic gets a bit into the weeds.
It's different than what we're doing.
This allows you to change things a bit
for your controllers.
We're not going to be messing with controller behavior.
We're going to keep things pretty straightforward.
All right, so let's go ahead back to the slides.
So now we're going to take a peek here
and I'm going to show you just what we have in here
for the slides for you.
And again, we're not going to go
through every single thing here.
This talks about all the different options
that you have with DMX.
We have another one here that talks
about all the different options that you have
when it comes to your OSC.
And then we also have another one for MIDI.
So I kind of break it down a bit here,
make it a little bit so that you can understand
the options that you have.
Because at Unreal, we want you drunk with power.
We want you to feel like you have amazing control
and you can do whatever you need for your project.
So note on binding.
Let's talk about this for a minute.
So if you save a new version of level
and you want to use the existing RCP
remote control preset that you've made,
you can rebind the property.
This extends into other capabilities as well,
including simply changing which asset is impacted.
To reassign, click on the desired actor to reassign here.
Now, I don't have any actors in another level
that I want to reach out to,
but you can actually go in there
and you can find them if you need to,
and you can rebind those assets as needed.
And we're not going to do this in this particular class.
Don't have a whole lot of time,
but I wanted to be able to point that out
because that option is there for you.
But let's talk a little bit about the blueprint options
where you can do some mapping for your blueprints.
So in here, with nearly boundless opportunities,
boundless, expanding, so many things you can do with RCP
to interact with scenes, assets, and organization,
again, I showed you how you can reorganize your rows,
you can shovel things around, you can make a group,
you can rename them,
and you can also expose the blueprint libraries.
Now, this is experimental, so just keep this in mind.
This has been out for a while,
but you still want to be careful and tread with caution.
You'll notice there are two icons,
which I pointed out earlier,
at the bottom of your screen.
So let's go ahead and take a look at Unreal,
and I can point some of those things out to you in Unreal.
So in Unreal, at the very bottom,
and again, our tool tips aren't active for these right now.
I can go in here and I can choose an actor class
that I have ready to go,
that I want to be able to work with.
I can also go in here
and choose a blueprint function library.
So again, we're not going to get that deep in this one,
but these gives you options
if you wanted to be able to bind objects
in those particular blueprints that are available for them
to be able to get those things
set up in the right direction.
So let's go back to the slides here.
So now what we're going to do is take a look,
a quick overview here,
at our options that we have when it comes to organizing
and building this whole web app interface for yourself
and for what you want to do.
It's really a simple, no-code UI editor.
It's pretty simple to use.
It quickly assigns your remote control preset widgets,
creates and sorts specific tabs,
and I'll show you how to do that in a bit.
Supports Chrome, Firefox, and Safari,
can run multiple web clients
if you needed to simultaneously,
creates restores, love snapshots.
We'll talk about level snapshots towards the end
and supports multi-user and display session usage.
Web app configuration stored
in the remote control preset asset.
So it actually, the remote control shell,
that interface, that asset that we have,
allows us to be able to access those items
that we've exposed within our web application.
And it's actually pretty nice to work with.
And it's pretty easy.
And we'll get to that in just a second here.
So what's happening a little bit under the hood here
is you're getting a Node.js,
you're getting this code under the hood
for your web control interface,
and it's active and working in the background.
Now, when you install Unreal in 5.1,
all of this should work fluidly
and work cleanly for you.
But if you're in 5.0, which I mentioned earlier,
you may run into an issue where pixel streaming
may have overwritten some of the code that you had
for 5.0 to use the web application.
And I'll show you how you can work around that
because it's a little tricky,
but you'll have to navigate
and make it so that Unreal looks at the older code
versus the newer code.
Now, and also 5.0 versus 5.1, I want to point this out.
You can turn this option on,
use less CPU when in the background.
That was important for older versions of Unreal,
like 4.27, 5.0.
5.1, you may or may not need to use this,
but what it does is you turn this on.
This depends on your system.
It allows you to use less CPU in the background.
So if you're getting a lag with your iPad,
you may want to go ahead and explore this
and see if you can help things out a bit
if things are a little bit on the slow end.
So what we're going to do here in just a bit,
we're going to go to the iPad
and I'm going to show you how to set this up.
Now we talked about in your address,
we talked about how you're going to have that 30,000
in your IP towards the end.
What you're going to do is when you send this
out the door to your iPad,
you want to make sure that instead of this setup here,
where you see a generic IP that we put in here,
you want to put in your IP for your computer
and then you want to put colon 30,000.
So whatever computer is talking to your iPad,
this is what you're going to punch into the URL
when you're like in Chrome or Firefox or Safari,
you want to have this set in with your Unreal.
Now, let me show you how that works.
So I'm going to do this generically first
and then we're going to go to the iPad later on,
but I'm going to show you what's going on.
So we're going to do this first via the internet.
You'll notice there's a web app launch button
here at the top.
We've chosen to work with our key light here
and you'll also notice that we have our beach rock.
We're not going to mess with him.
I just put him in there for now,
but we're going to mainly focus with the light
in this particular example.
So we can also use even color correct regions
if you wanted to with this, which is pretty handy.
So I'm going to click on the web app launch
and now you'll notice it goes to the web,
but at the same time,
this is also going to my iPad, believe it or not.
I'm working through a web browser.
We are now in control where we can build our IP,
color correct, playlist, all these things snapshot.
We can play with them.
I'm going to go to my design here
and we show our sample remote control preset
that we've already made.
This has a quite a few things in here.
If we go to properties,
you'll be able to see all the things
that you have listed.
Now in mine, I forgot this one's kind of empty
with the sample, but if we go to the new in class
and we go to our properties,
you'll see that we have the beach rock up close,
the relative rotation, the light color and the intensity.
All these are in here,
populating within a remote control preset
because we exposed those assets.
So we're going to go back
and we're going to talk about
being able to make your own icons, create your own tab.
We'll do this in just a bit
and we're going to mess with some of these settings here
but let's go ahead
and go back to our slides for a moment.
So when I was talking about you guys having issues,
and again, I put this code in here,
it's available for you.
If you guys are having issues with 5.0
and you can't get it to launch
because of the Pixel streaming conflict,
what you can do is run this code
and you'll have to go into your Unreal virtual web
remote control interface web app
and we want to go in there.
We want to go to the start bat
and we want to edit that start bat
and put this line of code in here.
And you're basically rerouting run reels
looking for this code to activate the app.
It's making it so it's not looking at the newest code
but it's looking at this older Node.js code
to be able to work.
Now in 5.1, you shouldn't have that problem.
I've tested it and it works just fine
but for 5.0, you may run into that issue
and 4.27, you should be okay
but I believe in 5.1 is where the issues
are acting a little weird.
Just keep those things in mind.
Some of you guys may not have a problem, I'm not sure.
I forget which version sometimes does that
but I left this code in here
just in case you guys run into that issue.
So again, we'll know that we have success
when we type in the remote control web here
and you know that your web app
has successfully launched.
Again, you'll see in the interface here,
we have our web app to be able to launch it
and you'll also see that we have design and control.
So let's talk a bit about design
because what we're going to do now
is we're going to edit and toggle
between control and design
and I'm going to show you how you can edit them.
In the next section, we're going to be building
the remote control preset interface.